i actually want to get personal or i
want to get close
so
everybody take off your pants so a lot
of the things that
you guys do it's a big
it's a big family
venture right we all got to do this
together we reap the rewards together
and that's what we see from the outside
and i think um that's what
that's what's awesome about having a
team
but also
the teams are made up of team mates
which are individuals
and so like one thing i always wanted to
know is
out of all the things that you've done
right and like let's say the world does
end for some reason and you're on an
island by yourself or you're just by
yourself for some reason
post-apocalyptic
what is something that you've done
that you feel like you can pat yourself
on the back for you're like you know
what i know i live in this world by
myself
but [ __ ] that was tight you know oh
that is a good question
i mean
again my head's in the clouds but right
now the [ __ ] nike [ __ ] that we just
did yeah is like
uh
for the culture yeah i think uh legacy i
think the word legacy comes by yeah like
we just talked about the noodles stuff
yeah that's like [ __ ] cool yeah
that's not like necessarily like my
legacy yeah you know what i mean um
but with what we just did with uh
being the lead consultants and
co-designing with tinker hatfield
the new dance shoe for nike and it's not
like
it's not like um not payless
[Laughter]
it's uh
what am i trying to say
if i were like a sick ass basketball
player in today's world it's like like
kyrie or something like that yeah i need
to make another shoot it's not like
there are all these other shoes before
me kobe's in jordan
this is like there's no other
concept of this before to the point
where when we had to go and do uh shoot
testing for this thing and like actually
before they even developed the shoe they
needed to learn about how dancers move
so they had to take us in with our
regular dance shoes whatever we normally
get down with and they had to do like
you know those scientific studies and
measures you wear like converse and
other shoes i don't know
all right well converse is owned by
nike's okay good point technically it's
fine all right but like if we were
rocking shelters it was just like
literally they were saying show up in
what you show up with that's not the
point just show up in what you show up
with so we go to campus and uh they take
us down in the innovation center where
they do like lab testing actual lab
testing and it takes this basement and
the hanger doors literally look like
[ __ ] you're just in a bunker is it
like some dude with like a badge like or
like retina scan type [ __ ] like
everything from like the craziest ndas
i've ever signed in my life to like you
know to badges and fingerprint [ __ ] like
it's like
it's like some white house type [ __ ]
it's sick uh and you go down there and
it's like they take us to the basketball
room because there's no dance room like
that's how that's how brand new where
we're at with this whole thing they
don't even have a name for it or a
category and they're they're arguing on
whether or not it should even be called
dance you know what i mean like there's
so many it could be a movement shoe
exactly exactly um so there's a whole
whole
world of things that they have yet to
figure out where did where the guinea
pigs you know there's actually a
bittersweet feeling about it because
like we maybe started a dialogue we
didn't answer any problems we just
started dialogue you know what i mean
move the needle if you will but that i
think is that's enough for me to be
proud of in terms of the legacy because
there wasn't something beforehand so
even if we [ __ ] up the fact is it
happened and now now somebody can build
off of it you know what i'm saying
i remember sitting um
yeah they took us to where the
basketball uh people going there to test
their shoes because there's a there's a
basketball court so the flooring makes
the most sense for us it's not like
we're gonna dance mainly on turf right
so we go to the basketball floor and
there's a clear window you know on the
floor that has like weight sensors and
stuff cameras and lights so they can
track your foot movements it's clear
yeah just just a square like where the
free throw hole is right and then and
then toby hatfield tinker's brother
comes in and he's like sitting down with
me yeah
yeah he's huge he's like a sick ass vp
of the nike that kills it too by the way
damn from the internal in the shadows
yeah because i never even heard those
but i just know the legendary shot right
anyways um and he sits down with me
because i'm like sitting on the side
while other guys getting tested and
stuff and he's like
how you feeling and i was like this is
crazy uh this is i can't believe we're
here and he's like yeah uh lebron
recently was testing his stuff right
there amazing and i'm like my god i
don't even know what to do with that
information you know what i'm saying
like you're just like
okay
that's all you there's nothing oh yeah i
can't even measure the weight of what
that means as a dancer because there's
no other experience before us you know
what i mean and uh even just sitting in
it like the
the bungalow where they do like their
crazy innovation meetings with tinker
and being like and and trying to
be of uh an ambassador for dance even
beyond kindreds and just trying to say
honest things not you'll be sick like it
had these colors because our brand you
know it had nothing to do with us yeah
it was genuinely even being like
um we're a little worried that uh
like
one shoe is not gonna cut it like
dancers are fickle there's a lot of
different types of movers like a ballet
dancer is not going to kill you know
what i mean and it was one of those
moments where he had to seriously be
like like we know that
uh this isn't going to be the answer for
the entire culture but
people at the top people who make real
decisions for these kinds of things even
on behalf of nike sometimes they need
something to understand and believe in
and it starts with one thing you never
go well if you don't make the cause i'm
talking the wrong person
but you know what i'm saying it's kind
of like that's what you need so like i
think that's what we did we we started
with one thing
and if that were like the entirety of my
dance legacy i could honestly hang up my
shoes and be proud for myself even if
people don't understand the weight of
that you know what i'm saying because we
did that [ __ ] in the shadows too like
for four years look at that the branding
never changes in the showers for four
years
not allowed to talk about this [ __ ] you
know
for four years we've been doing it since
the end of december 7 2017 and the thing
is like straight up i started when i was
31 on that project i'm 35 now wow but
but here's the bittersweet part imagine
a 35 year old basketball player in the
nba
maybe they have great stats and legacy
and all this [ __ ] but not that good yeah
like you're looking at the [ __ ] 20
year old that's killing everyone yeah
you know what i'm saying and that i'm
i'm humbled to like be a part of
you know this moment for dance but i
also have to humble myself and
understand that like somebody else is
meant to pick up these shoes and do
something with it you know what i'm
saying i also feel like
like i don't know if you feel this way
or if other people perceive it this way
but because there has been no other
model for it
it's almost like um your guys's version
of going to space
you know what i mean yeah like for like
jeff bezos elon musk or whatever it's
like yeah we're using technology that
exists now but we're going into a
frontier that no one has ever been
we don't know what the uses of that
frontier are we just know that we need
to get there because that is obviously
the next step we've been staring at a
telescope at a moon for decades now
so it's like yeah dancers wear shoes and
the
athletes they move around and there
hasn't been a shoe designed for the
needs of a dancer so we have to take
that next step and who knows what
happens after then like you could
catapult a giant industry or it could be
nothing i think with the momentum of
paris 2024 olympics uh officially having
breaking yeah an involved b-boy and
b-girl in there that momentum plus where
we're at
this is like the moment like if there
was a moment of momentum that could push
the needle enough
for some [ __ ] out there to
suddenly be like let's put this [ __ ] on
espn let's make a reality tv show about
it let's do a netflix donkey series
about like a crew and follow it let's
like they do um that other you know like
the basketball the football
documentaries for like high school teams
and stuff but yeah like there can
it doesn't just have to be dance moms or
like a studio ballet nutcracker stuff
that's like traditional that people
understand like there's there's a whole
world and we just need enough momentum
at one time for the right people to kind
of pick up and and you know it's almost
like institutional money for bitcoin
this i feel like we're at like 2006 or
2009 for bitcoin but for like dancers
you know what i'm saying um and you just
hope and believe in something ideal
about it but we'll see we'll see who can
pick it up later